¿Sabes cuáles son los dos únicos
alimentos con los que podría sobrevivir
el ser humano?
Y no, no son ni el arroz, ni la pasta,
ni la carne, son los mejillones y esto
que tengo aquí, el coco. Imagínate que
te quedas atrapado en una isla desierta,
sin acceso a comida, sin ayuda, solo lo
que tienes alrededor. Pues
sorprendentemente esta combinación
podría mantenerte con vida durante un
tiempo. El coco es prácticamente energía
pura. contiene grasas que el cuerpo
transforma rápidamente en combustible,
además de agua, electrolitos y
minerales. Es uno de los alimentos
vegetales más completos que existen en
términos de supervivencia, pero tiene un
problema importante. Es pobre en
proteínas completas y no aporta vitamina
B12, algo esencial para el sistema
nervioso y función celular. Y aquí es
donde entran los mejillones, que son
justo lo que le falta al coco. Son
extremadamente ricos en proteínas de
alto valor biológico. Contienen vitamina
B12 en grandes cantidades, además de
hierro, zin, yodo y omega-3. Es decir,
aportan justo los micronutrientes y
aminoácidos esenciales que el coco no
tiene. Por eso, esta combinación tiene
sentido desde el punto de vista
nutricional. Uno te da energía y el otro
te da los elementos necesarios para que
el cuerpo funcione. Ahora bien,
sobrevivir no es lo mismo que estar
sano. Incluso con coco y mejillones
tendrías carencias. Por ejemplo, la
vitamina C sería insuficiente a largo
plazo, lo que podría provocar escorbuto,
una enfermedad clásica en contextos de
supervivencia. También faltaría
diversidad nutricional, algo clave para
mantener una microbiota saludable y
podrían aparecer desequilibrios por
exceso de ciertos nutrientes como el
yodo o las grasas saturadas. Así que sí,
podría sobrevivir durante un tiempo con
esta combinación, pero no es una dieta
completa ni equilibrada ni saludable a
largo plazo. Así que la próxima vez que
veas un coco en la playa, recuerda,
puede ayudarte a sobrevivir, pero no
sustituye a una dieta real. Yeah.